there was a period where mommy woke up
and cried 45 days straight I started
keeping a diary damn you missed some
days every morning I think that's the
worst I've ever felt in our marriage I
was failing miserably
Will Smith laying it all out there about
his marriage to Jada Pinkett Smith on
her Facebook watch show read table talk
data is then teasing the appearance
since read table talk launched earlier
this year what in the world are you
going to talk to Wilson will am I
actually gonna have a very interesting
conversation about how our journey in
regards to transforming a marriage into
a life partnership an understanding of
that and understanding more of that you
know you come to the episode but it's
gonna be a really powerful discussion
and how my mother and how willow and
Jaden the whole family has been involved
in this transformation so so you're
going to get to weigh in on it it's
gonna be my mother myself yeah he's so
ready it was his idea actually when he
was like cuz I wasn't gonna have him
mm-hmm come mm-hmm and he was like how
you not in how you not gonna have me
come to the table and I was like all
right you can come for episode 10 yeah I
was like you could cover episode 10 but
it's so beautiful I think I think that
will be a really great show too
we have found so much happiness
Union in a way that's very different
than most yeah wills full sit-down with
Jada daughter Willow and mother-in-law
Adrian serves as the season 2 premiere
of read Table Talk launching October
22nd so in October it's gonna it's a I
feel like it's a strong thirteen will is
our first guest
I also brought Leah Remini
we've got Jay Cole coming we have a lot
of great guests we're talking about
issues like domestic violence we're
talking about love and marriage we're
talking about just all kind of stuff
it's gonna be it's gonna be a really
great year great indeed here's more of
what you can expect via three
generations of when talking about the
world around us
I'm not afraid to talk about race my job
was to get you into Scientology he
started hitting me and he was in a rage
he told me I'd rather get hide and be
your father we don't even call ourselves
married anymore you had the courage to
tell your story
[Music]
that you drive at the red to be thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]